[Musique]
groupe compétition
déjà trois jours de marche dans les
jambes nos 18 ans d'honneur sur toujours
sur le pont pour la plupart d'entre eux
c'est leur première confrontation mais
fermons les masques sont tombés les
barrières sociales n'existent plus tu
n'es plus faibles peuvent désormais
compter sur la solidarité des pubs
bref c'est le métier qui rentre l'étape
du tour la quatrième est en fait une
étape intermédiaire entre le grand st
bernard ou la cabane de chanrion nous
sommes à mi-parcours à l'état brut
au cours des trois premières étapes et
randonneurs ont fait le plein d'émotions
ils ont déjà largement eu l'occasion de
découvrir que la haute route entre
chamonix et zermatt ne rime pas
forcément avec promenade de santé sur la
con tu dans lequel et ont battu va comme
j'te dis comme on y vivent comme une
canne d'accord voilà sa mort en mai
j'espère à bientôt
j'étais mieux dans ma vie mais lasses
debout maintenant pas touchés j'ai bien
vu l'extradition
ça va très bien on a encore des légumes
ou sur la rouge
[Musique]
au risque devrait tenir la corde bleu de
la main gauche alors là je sais pas ma
droite et ma gauche et tout de suite
c'est un boris tu trouves c'est presque
exagéré d'emmener un groupe comme ça
dans un niveau pareil bah ça dépend à
quel moment de la journée tu me poses
[Rires]
institut qu'est ce qu'on fout là j'ai
jamais eu peur disait tu as trouvé ça
super dur moi j'ai une copine à moi qui
me disent tu penses que je peux le faire
je dis non une fille aussi peu entre eux
dit moi moins chaud que c'est pas
impossible mais l'idéal savez préparez
les guidons donc décidé de profiter de
cette quatrième étape pour ménager leur
peine
tout en les initiant aux techniques
celle qui non content c'est pour bientôt
non c'est pas grave les salons ta fille
qui va trancher
alors on entendu ce n'est en arrière tu
prends ton monocorde avec des morts et
puis dit bush n'avait pas été là bas moi
j'ai appris que j'étais capable
finalement de faire plein de choses dont
j'avais peur et dont je me croyais
incapable de les apprécier
et puis les faire payer aux autres pour
faire des petits sauts bien douées en
fait j'ai pas beaucoup réfléchi
d'ailleurs je pense que si j'avais
réfléchi je serais pas venu faut être
clair ce que je me voyais pas faire un
truc comme ça je déteste le froid j'aime
pas dormir à 35 surtout des gens que je
connais pas je n'aime pas me lever le
matin très tôt
j'aime pas spécialement faire des
efforts et pis là bas ça fait ch pas
combien de jours qu'on aime parce que
même ça j'ai perdu la notion du temps et
en fait j'ai vraiment appris à aimer
plein de trucs à priori j'aimais pas
dupe à andré lafon louvre ouais je suis
prête chacun je pense à ces limites à
dépasser c'est pas le but qui compte
sept chemins
il faut mettre le baudrier de se tenir
au centre toute la province alors que
l'on doit faire la tyrolienne
ça peut servir plus tard dans la course
des fois on a des pompes qu'ils achètent
toujours bon à l'entraînement et monique
alémanique
si j'ai un malaise qu'est ce qui se
passe dans sa bouche ce qu'il va faire
mais vous avez remarqué que j'ai mis une
touche de rouge à lèvres coquetterie
dans la manche
[Musique]
tout le monde y passe
ils font prix monique 65 ans la doyenne
[Musique]
alors
c'est monique olalalala affirme annick
[Musique]
c'est peu mais c'est un chien vous
assure jamais trop su gérer ce cas de
machines
test du très bon c'est pas mon truc
maintenant plus part d'entre eux d'en
dévoiler une nouvelle fois la tête et il
a besoin et regardera malekesa des
conseillers pour le papa mais c'est bon
j'ai dû rechange dire changeant la
trousse monty nécessaire de beauté
samedi une goutte de combat c'est bon on
fait quand même maintenant la 2 comment
on fait il faut se tenir
j'imagine la haute route initiale à 4
août
on dirait qu'on fait des choses bizarres
[Musique]
me recentre aucune fatigue des premiers
jours demain autant dire qu'ils en
redemandent
[Musique]
ça pète
je compris vous auriez régime est
bienvenu président qui peut être été
clôturée ménage est fait là maintenant
pour
moi je voudrais faire deux fois
[Musique]
alors là je suis déconnecté je ne sais
même pas quel jour on est j'ai oublié le
temps j'ai oublié tout le stress de la
ville
j'ai oublié mon vélo même j'ai tout
oublié là je pense pas au lendemain par
exemple ce qu'on peut faire dans une
ville
je me laisse couler dans l'énergie dans
le temps
on peut dépenser
isabelle les journalistes mais elle est
surtout obstinément optimiste
coucou à la première fois de ma vie j'ai
vu cinq à l'élevage
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
émouvant la première fois mentionné un
petit peu en montagne quand même depuis
depuis 30 35 ans première fois que j'en
avais vu des vrais comme ça dans
l'entretien c'était super c'est très
ludique ya quand même le l'émotion de la
première fois et rien à faire quand tu
vois pas toutes les premières fois
j'entendais rien mais le premier déjà ce
que tu vois c'est émouvant
vraiment c'est une rencontre cette
petite faire aussi vulnérable qu'un
souffle dans l'univers comme nous les
humains à méditer
[Musique]
sa famille elle j'aimerais chacun s'en
soucie bush et les bouches bleus c'est
pas de la serviette après tort aux
salles il ya durant mara là dedans du
thym du temps mal à l'aise au milieu
plein harriet romarin sauge laisse
réfléchir un excellent annoncé jeudi
ce n'est plus un bertrand mais
puisqu'elle passe à ce que je suis dans
ce métier a ses moments d donc ça sent
bon jeune épidermique roddick 7-6 quoi
sont les week-ends ou rien à madame
quand monsieur en bois fait du bien aux
hommes comme suit en bois commencé
tambour comme son renvoi en ce1 ce2
comme ceux qui en abusent
j'ai la voiture mais air de bonne soeur
je le fais double hauteur pesant une
[Applaudissements]
autre dimension en fait à paris je pense
qu'on ferme ces petits osselets
tellement il ya de bruit puis on est
assez fermé sur soi ici ça ouvre les
yeux qui ça ouvre les oreilles puis ça
doit ouvrir d'autres choses dont on
n'avait pas conscience avant
[Musique]
ce qui est important c'est toutes ses
sensations nouvelles de tous les jours
et puis le fait d'être un groupe quoi
j'avais oublié ça où je l'avais jamais
connu puis nous on est du coup plaisir
et du plaisir pendant la hall et les non
c'est pas bon olé olé l'ebre l'imamat
cas si bien qu'il a apprise est d'accord
personne ne s'est pas répétée happy when
dix espoirs way
[Musique]
j'aime pas trop sur nos la normale pour
ses chorégraphies tion du mode horde il
tente en tente elite et quand je n'aurai
plus le temps de trouver tout le temps
du courage quand j'aurai mis vingt ans à
voir que tout était mirage
alors j'entends au fond de moi une
petite voix qui so des comptes que je
suis seul au monde
[Musique]
heureusement je me retourne et vous êtes
là c'est cool alors après l'effort
le feeling est passé
c'est pas une question moi même et je
crois que leurs pattes le milieu social
soit soit une barrière avant tout on est
des êtres humains quoi c'est pas je vois
par exemple boris 1
on est souvent ensemble et à un moment
donné j'ai entendu des gens qui
croyaient course qu'on essaie depuis
longtemps alors qu'en même temps ça va
commencer leur en juillet enfin chez
molex
et voilà ils bossent en suisse il ya des
finances moi je vais du dans le 93 à
paris il ya salle avoir cessé ce
quelqu'un je pense que je n'aurais
jamais rencontré si je me tais pas
inscrits à cette aventure
mais là on dirait comme s'il avait dû
tellement pris dans les codes ridant
comment on est présentée quand on va au
bureau quand on en contact avec les gens
et tout un rasage coiffage tout parfait
parfait la d'objets de lâcher prise
si on a deux sacs à dos donc tu lâche
prise pis tu acceptes de sentir le maso
pitt accepte de faire les pieds
ils sont pas terribles à tous puis voilà
quoi
c'est pas le milieu social qui fait que
l'on se plaît bien montagne pas tous
égaux dans la montagne
[Musique]
marchons qu'un sang impur abreuve nos
sillons
donc aujourd'hui on est le 14 juillet on
ait peu de français non être dans le
groupe et je me suis fait mon feu
d'artifice j'en ai pris plein les yeux
[Applaudissements]
la france vous avez une pensée pour tous
ceux qui verront jamais ce paradis parce
que farhad il existe il est là
la ctq autres aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
régine pour demain oui on essaye encore
demain oui mais il faut pas nager quand
j'ai compris surtout passer encore une
couche de boue qui s'enlacent il faut
surtout pas laisser venir élections
sinon après celle du seuil de douleur
avant la mort j'ai une prend la main de
francs soit une âme et dans ta bouche et
quand ça témoigne tu sers sans que
l'électro cardiogramme est stable parce
que c'est qu'on produit la deuxième peau
et intègre à la blessure ça soigne sa
sèche assez vite mais bon si qui marche
pas si tu marches sais pas trop je
pensais quand même pas mal mais ça va
soigner les mouches qui arrivent déjà
régime aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
elles sont à l'affût or elles sont là
latin atteindre le morceau de viande
pour émettre une rondelle de saucisson
aussi ça très bien
là ça devrait quand même tenir tout neuf
sites la sculpture là c'est de la
sculpture
elle a les pieds en compote el amal un
orteil mal à ça à ses talons et hier
hier pendant plus de deux heures de
marche
elle était souffrante elle gémit ce
plusieurs fois je vais demander est-ce
que ça va aller
tu veux tu arrêter donne alors on y va
on y va on y va à caractère très très
fort et c'est sa volonté son caractère
qu'il a fallu jusqu'au bout absolument
pas question d'abandonner cette montagne
peut-être j'ai l'impression comme si
c'était un appel tu vois j'ai envie
d'aller jusqu'au bout c'est c'est plus
fort que moi mais c'est pas hasard non
plus si j'ai cette ampoule peut-être
aussi ça me remet en question par
rapport à mon impatience
je veux toujours aller trop vite je vais
toujours foncé bon j'apprends j'apprends
les choses
[Musique]
on
c'est ce qu'il faut pas tout oublier
comme se décide il faut pas que tu
oublies c'est de regarder ce que je veux
dire par exemple sont entrés tu l'a
dessinée tu vois comme une porte
d'entrée
d'accord il a fait un truc le truc est
tout blanc tu la fais tout moi je vois
tu vas le rapport de contraste que tu as
de ce qui en fait après si je fais les
petits carreaux on distingue ouais si tu
regardes bien le porche d'entrée il est
noir
niva blanc
jours
c'est bien mais qui continue j'ai bien
fatigué comme ça
ce que vous dites est rentré dans leur
petit frère en 30 secondes chacun son
rythme on n'a pas pu s'empêcher de
mettre le drapeau
non là il est en train de voler
maintenant ça foire imagine tu prends
une photo à montréal tous avantages je
crois qu'il fixe et pas une photo celle
là les volets ils sont rentrés ce pas
d'ici enfin l envie en fait tu fais toi
plaisir
je ne présente plus en prendre la
hauteur plus le vocabulaire nous manque
parfois j'ai arrêté d'écrire est par
contre j'ai trouvé une
une forme d'expression qui me convenait
beaucoup plus qui est l agriculture ça
c'est alexandra bonin la danseuse
vollaro par battement ça c'est papa
micolon regarder le paysage des enfants
[Rires]
voilà on arriva à monique françois en
train de traîner monique par la corde et
moi j'imagine un peu le bruit fait un
peu le pas de munich est certes régulier
mais il est très long trop long aux yeux
de ses camarades de candeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après quatre jours de ce régime
escargots tout le monde affiche
ouvertement son impatience
on est pressé de montaut paradis tu
avais l'autre espace de liberté
aujourd'hui mais alors ça suffit
c'est une immense surprise de voir le
rythme a amené quoi c'est fascinant quoi
mais on serait ce là les deux os qui toi
et moi pour les miens qui passe je te
l'on sait qu'au match qu'au début c'est
vrai qu'on sent bien que tous les autres
dans un groupe ce faux rythme il n'est
pas facile tu vois non c'est qu'à se
fier c'est fatiguant de diviser son par
deux c'est fatigant mais bon on a un
groupe un groupe qui doit évoluer et
moment donné il faut prendre une
décision il faut se poser la question
est ce que en tout prix je veux aller
mais effectivement là c'est de dire bon
pour que le reste du groupe finissent
cette expédition le plus sereinement
possible
je me retire dès qu'il a caressé celle
des dit qu'il est un petit peu tâté le
que j'ai compris où il voulait en venir
je lui ai dit tout de suite plutôt que
se sorte de petit discussions infinies
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça le
problème n'est pas là le cerveau est ce
qu on fait encore une étape avec toi et
puis est ce que tout le monde d'accord
de faire ses tableaux ou en acceptant ce
rythme moi je trouve que mon nom va
lentement mais au moins bon et qu'on n'a
pas le short milliers quand on arrive et
puis je sais pas où on n'est pas morts
on sait pas si on faisait bouger devant
prendre on dormira presque jamais déjà
pour s'être concertés et tout mais je
pense qu'on pourrait quand même trouvé
un compromis c'est-à-dire ne pas m'être
monique derrière toi et peut-être la met
au milieu de la colonne mais pas la
mettre au milieu et à la fin
il fut fait mais presque se rend pas
compte parce qu'elle est peut-être que
je n'imagine pas une corde et de guides
étaient à la fin demain si tu me dis que
la montée régulière comme le chemin qui
m'a monté tu peux accélérer le jeu peut
accélérer le pas est ce qu'en dit qu'est
ce que certains qui colle et là il faut
que chacun si on fait ça demain il faut
que d'une part toi tu fais le compromis
doit il essaye d'aller un petit peu plus
vite et les autres accepter encore un
journée d'aller plus loin
alors après tout ce que tu te sens tu me
[Rires]
fais honte et monique ne pense pas après
demain pense à demain et on fait cette
cordée ensemble pauvres alors de me
coucher tôt et la unión volonté il y
aussi d'éviter une chaîne elle se mesure
à la résistance sont aimons plus faibles
la cadette du groupe russe sur la
doyenne demain fini les petites fleurs
bonjour la route montagne la journée
sera non seulement longue sera surtout
décisive
[Musique]
décors sublimes même pour les 5e et 6e
étape
une journée test pour mo'nique qui va
devoir oublier sa fatigue pour mieux
composer avec sa souffrance
le mauvais temps en invité surprise nos
dix marcheurs sont au coeur de la hausse
mental sur six chaînes se fait rare la
fatigue s'accumule au pied du mur
en l'occurrence les échelles
vertigineuse d'un refuge de l'évent
[Musique]